[Musique]
elle a fait interdire en France une
milice nationaliste turque et déclarer
la guerre à une influenceuse au 2
millions d'abonnés ceux qui l'ont côtoyé
la décrivent comme discrète mais
obstinée ce qui l'a sans doute aidé à se
faire élire député renaissance du
[Musique]
rô bonjour Sarah tanzidi bonjour alors
vos deux parents sont d'origine
arménienne ils ont toujours vécu en
France mais voilà ils sont très liés à
ce pays vous aussi qu'est-ce que ça
signifie pour vous être d'origine
arménienne bah écoutez c'est l'histoire
de ma famille et c'est une forme
d'héritage pour moi c'est d'abord ça et
puis je crois que c'est rapidement aussi
devenu pour moi un engagement un
combat pour
porter la cause d'un peuple qui est très
très méconnu et qui pour autant a été
frappé d'une immense injustice et donc
ça bouleverse et on a envie de porter ça
donc c'est effectivement votre tout
premier engagement avant l'engagement
purement politique il y a eu cet
engagement pour défendre la la cause
arménienne très jeune dans différentes
association et puis de filand en
aiguille vous avez aussi présidé la
Maison de la culture et du peuple
arménien à dessine dans le Rône et c'est
dans le cadre de ces fonctions vous avez
pris la parole le 24 juillet 2020 une
prise de parole on va le voir qui a été
interrompu assez
rapidement l'Arménie souveraine et
indépendante est
attaquée en pleine période de pandémie
mondiale
l'Azerbaïjan a décidé de mettre ses
menaces je vous demande de rester calme
messieurs
dames messieur dames s'il vous plaît ça
sert à rien d'y aller à 100 reste calme
alors sur ces images on comprend qu' est
en train de se passer c'est quelque
chose derrière la caméra mais on
comprend pas bien quoi qu'est-ce qui
alors en réalité cette ce rassemblement
qui avait qui avait lieu suite à une
offensive de l'Azerbaïdjan sur l'Arménie
en soutien à l'Arménie euh a fait
l'objet d'une attaque euh de jeunes de
la région qui se revendiquaient d'un
groupuscule ultra
naationaliste et mafieux qui s'appelle
les loups gris et donc on a euh on a
fait face à de jeunes hommes
pour certains armés de couteau de barre
de fer c'est ça couteau de barre de fer
qui
cherchaiit à se battre tuer frapper les
Arméniens qui sonnaient au au port dans
la rue vous imagineiez vivre ça un jour
en France sur le territoire français
c'est non à aucun moment ça a été
effectivement un moment
bouleversant je regardais ces images
avec un peu d'anxiété parce que ça me
rappelle effectivement des mauvais
moments et ça s'est passé donc à deux
reprises à dessine avec cette milice
nationaliste
turque avec plusieurs associations vous
avez demandé et obtenu l'interdiction
donc des loups gris en France est-ce que
ça vous a valu des menaces de leur part
est-ce que j'ai pas de reçu de menace
directes mais je pense que ces
organisations connaissent les
associations qui qui portent ces sujets
notamment le com de défense de la cause
arménienne dont j'étais membre et avec
qui on a on a déposé cette demande de
dissolution et donc il y a bien
évidemment une pression quand on connaît
les acteurs là on les voit défiler
justement lors de l'une de ces de ces
descentes dans dans les rues de de
dessine les Arméniens forment une
communauté très soudée vous-même vous
êtes donc une membre active de cette de
cette communauté et en même temps vous
revendiquez votre attachement aux
valeurs républicaines est-ce que le
communautarisme est compatible avec le
modèle républicain
français moi vous savez je suis une
enfant de la République
euh je suis le produit de l'école de la
République c'est ce qui m'a construit
intellectuellement c'est ce qui m'a
façonné et c'est aussi ça qui a
construit finalement mon engagement donc
il y a un vrai lien entre les deux je
crois qu'il y a pas de difficulté à ce
qui puissent y avoir des communautés en
France à condition qu'elles sachent
toutes et qu'elles aient toutes en tête
euh que notre bien commun à tous et à
toutes celles qui ceux qui garantis
notre liberté ce sont les principes de
la République dans votre famille votre
frère vous a précédé en quelque sorte en
politique vous êtes plutôt discrète sur
le sujet mais bon il a quandême
travailler pour deux figures importantes
du Parti socialiste il a été
collaborateur parlementaire de François
Hollande et ensuite il a été conseiller
parlementaire de Bernard casneuve
d'abord au ministère de l'Intérieur puis
à Matignon ça veut dire que la la
politique avait une une place importante
dans votre famille ou euh pour que il
quand même la politique avait une place
importante c'est-à-dire que je sais pas
si c'est le cas dans toutes les familles
mais nous ça nous arrivait très souvent
de parler politiques entre nous à table
avec nos parents et euh on on a un
engagement commun aussi pour la cause
arménienne avec mon frère euh on n' pas
forcément toujours les mêmes idées mais
je crois que ça nous a appris
l'engagement l'engagement politique
l'importance que ça peut avoir le fait
que ça peut changer la vie des gens et
donc que c'est important et que ça
compte HM j'ai lu que votre père euh est
engagé à gauche tendance plutôt
socialiste je crois que votre mère elle
elle est plutôt à droite plutôt elle est
pasarté elle a pas d'engagement
politique mais elle a des idées qui sont
plutôt de droites oui c'est pour
concilier les deux que vous avez choisi
Emmanuel Macron c'est bah finalement
peut-être que mon expérience personnelle
m'a montré qu'il y avait du bon et à
gauche et à droite hm hm alors vousmême
vous avez d'abord eu une carrière de
fonctionnaire territoriale à Lyon les
gens qui vous ont connu dans dans ces
fonctions vous étiez juristes à la
métropole de Lyon ils vous décrivent
comme discrète mais obstiné on peut
faire de la politique quand on est
quelqu'un de discret bah écoutez a
priori manifestement oui euh je pense
que la première des qualités c'est
effectivement
euh l'obstination une forme d'opinatreté
c'est-à-dire vraiment une volonté
d'aboutir et d'atterrir une
énergie je pense que c'est important
mais quand on est homme ou femme
politique il faut convaincre il faut
aller vers les autres il faut il faut se
vendre en quelque sorte je pense que la
discrétion n'empêche pas ça HM euh la
discrétion c'est parfois être un peu
intimidé dans un moment comme celui
qu'on est en train de vivre et pas être
forcément très attiré par les médias en
revanche je pense que dans une relation
personnelle individuelle euh j'ai une
capacité à aller vers l'autre qui est
beaucoup plus importante pour obtenir
l'investiture d'un parti au législative
en général on milite sur le terrain on
prend des responsabilités localement
vous vous avez pris un chemin différent
euh vous avez été collaboratrice
parlementaire de la député Daniel
casarian en 2017 et vous lui avez
succédé comment est-ce que les choses se
sont faites si Daniel casarian avait
fait le choix euh d'être à nouveau
candidate à sa succession il était tout
à fait logique que ce soit elle qui qui
porte la candidature elle a fait un
choix différent et la question qui s'est
posé à moi c'est de savoir ce que moi
j'avais envie de faire à ce moment-là et
ce que j'avais envie de faire c'était
vraiment de continuer à défendre les les
intérêts des habitants de mon territoire
c'est presque une mini France en fait
cette circonscription il y a plein de
choses il y a une vraie diversité c'est
un territoire voilà qui m'a plu auquel
je me suis attachée que j'avais vraiment
envie de défendre à l'Assemblée
nationale à l'Assemblée vous travaillez
plus particulièrement sur la défense des
droits des femmes et des et des enfants
et c'est dans ce contexte que vous avez
effectué un signalement auprès du
procureur de roin contre une
influenceuse poupette Kenza qu'est-ce
que vous lui reprochiez exactement
écoutez je lui reprochais d'avoir publié
notamment une
photo de sa fille dans une
position relativement
suggestive et et donc de mettre en
danger son enfant je crois qu'on ne
mesure
pas l'importance et la gravité que ça
peut avoir pour ses enfants d'être
exposé aussi jeune et d'être exposé
comme ça c'estd que ces im en fait sur
cette photo qu'on a choisi he de ne pas
montrer voyez la petite culotte de de
cet enfant et cette photo vous dites que
elle a circulé ensuite sur des sites
pédophiles c'est ça elle a CIRC circuler
enfin le nom de cette jeune fille en
tout cas de cette petite fille a circulé
sur des sites pédopornographiques sur le
Dark web h donc il y a une vraie
exposition de cet enfant malheureusement
elle continue donc autant vous savez je
pense que les parents de 2023
2024 moi je comprends tout à fait qu'on
se rendre pas for forcément compte de ce
qu'on fait quand on publie des photos de
nos enfants sur les réseaux mais quand
on sait que nos enfants sont en top
tendance de site pédopornographique je
connais pas beaucoup de parents qui
continueraientent à à publier ce genre
d'images de leurs enfants donc derrière
ce signalement à la justice et a la
question du droit à l'image des enfants
c'est un sujet sur lequel vous
travaillez avec votre collègue Bruno
Studer est-ce que le procureur a a donné
suite à votre signalement ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que il y a un certain
nombre des follower de cette jeune femme
qui ont participé au cyber harcèlement
qu'elle a voulu organiser à mon
encontrre qui sont exactement qui ont
été euh qui ont été reçus qui ont été
auditionnés il y a des procédures qui
sont en cours moi ce que je souhaite
c'est pas forcément de stigmatiser ces
jeunes filles là parce que c'est
essentiellement quand même des jeunes
filles ce que je souhaite c'est que
cette femme qui elle est une adulte et
qui a euh
lancer ce cyberhcelement elle soit
responsable voilà VO responsabité voit
effectivement l'un des messages qu'elle
a adressé à ses abonnés signalons en
masse ce tweet qui incite à la haine au
harcèlement vers mes enfants et moi et
dans la foulée effectivement vous avez
reçu des messages
d'insultes sur Twitter notamment là on
en voit quelques-uns je les lis parce
que peut-être que c'est compliqué à lire
sur cet écran mais sale tu tu n'as
pas honte Sarah la je vais te
piétiner retourne en en Arménie te faire
génocider
euh vous avez déposé plainte contre elle
euh ça a donné quelque chose pour
l'instant ou c'est encore en cours c'est
encore en cours en fait on a si je vous
pose toutes ces questions c'est que on a
le sentiment que la loi elle est un peu
en retard sur la société et la loi sont
les députés qui la font la loi elle est
aussi en train de se faire en ce moment
et vous le disiez tout à l'heure sur la
question notamment du droit à l'image de
l'enfant moi je pense que la proposition
que que qui est rapportée par mon
collègue Bruno Studer et que je je
soutiens c'est une proposition qui est
intéressante qui est équilibrée parce
que ça permettrait dans des cas comme
ceuxla d'empêcher les enfants de les
parents de continuer à publier des
images de leurs enfants c'est quelque
chose de d'efficace et d'équilibré donc
on est encore en train de faire la loi
vous avez raison mais sur la
responsabilité pénale en cas de
harcèlement je pense que le cadre
législatif il est là maintenant c'est au
juge de faire son travail ah on va
passer à un sujet plus léger notre quiz
euh je vous explique le principe vous
allez devoir compléter les phrases que
je vais vous vous proposer on y va quand
j'étais collaboratrice parlementaire au
moins je pouvais
euh je pouvais passer les soirées en
famille ouais ce qui n'est plus
dansémicycles non c'est plus compliqué
en tant que député d'abord parce qu'il y
a une activité parlementaire nocturne
qui est importante et puis parce que
quand on est en circonscription on est
sollicité aussi sur ces ces tr son
horaire là et comme j'ai deux petits
garçons h et bien ça me coûte un peu
vous les voyez si je devais boire un
verre avec un adversaire politique ce
serait oh là là euh bah peut-être
Frédéric Mathieu qui copréside avec moi
qui est député de la France insoumise et
qui donc à ce titre làà plutôt un
adversaire mais en même temps qui
co-préside avec moi le groupe d'études
sur les Kurdes h donc vous arrivez à
travailler en bonne intelligence on
arrive à travailler ensemble
effectivement enfin j'aurais réussi mon
mandat si
j'aurais réussi mon mandat si
j'arrive à mieux protéger les enfants
victimes de violence c'est votre
priorité moi j'ai été bouleversée par ça
je pense que c'est le point de départ de
beaucoup de de drame de notre société
beaucoup de difficultés que ces enfants
peuvent rencontrer ensuite adultes sont
liés à ce qu'ils ont vécu de leur
enfance et je crois que vraiment enfin
depuis que j'ai pris conscience de la
gravité de ça je me dis que si j'arrive
à en sauver certains à l'occasion de mon
mandage j'aurait été utile merci
beaucoup Sarah tzili d'être venu dans la
politique et moi merci à
[Musique]
vous